Brasil está de vuelta en la agenda
internacional Este es el mensaje que dio
el presidente de elector Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva quien se reunió con tres
de los nueve gobernadores de la amazonía
brasileña aquí a mis espaldas desde ahí
Lula anunció que se reunirá con el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez para pedirle que Brasil sea el
país anfitrión de la Copa 30 que se
realizará en 2025 Y es que los
gobernadores amazónicos le pidieron que
la amazonía sea la sede central y Lula
dijo que así lo pedirá para que esto se
vea no solo en el papel sino también en
la realidad Por otra parte Lula anunció
la creación de un Ministerio de pueblos
originarios para afirmar que trabajará
conjuntamente con los indígenas en la
protección amazónica por otro lado el
presidente Lula firmó con el consorcio
legal de la amazonía que reúne a los
gobernadores de esta región de Brasil
para tomar la carta con la que se
compromete a trabajar y proteger esta
región con un desarrollo sostenible Por
otra parte al final de hoy Lula dará su
discurso oficial en la Cope en el que
dijo que dará varios anuncios uno de los
más esperados es que quién será su
ministro o ministra de medio ambiente